bonjour à toutes et tous et le premier
set 8 sociétés de l'année j'en profite
donc pour vous souhaiter à toutes et
tous une bonne année 2016 qu'elle puisse
être une année de débats de partage et
des changes
un constat qui ne vous aura pas échappé
la restauration rapide se développe à
grande vitesse à saint quentin en
yvelines et ses environs avec notamment
la bataille que se livrent deux
mastodontes du secteur mcdonald's et
burger king entre autres quelles sont
les conséquences de ses multiples
implantations sur l'économie locale sur
le commerce de proximité en termes
d'emploi de collaboration avec les
filières de production locale la montée
en puissance de la restauration rapide
se fait-elle au détriment de la
restauration traditionnelle
autant de questions que nous allons
intenter auquel nous avons tenté de
répondre avec nos quatre invités et
krikor dinars ayant d'abord bonsoir vous
êtes restaurateur à saint quentin en
yvelines à membres du groupement
national des indépendants ile de france
comme ailleurs dit bonsoir ans
maintenant vous êtes maire adjoint à
l'urbanisme à l'environnement et la
qualité de vie à trappes
gilles bombard bonsoir soir vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat cgt
mcdonald's paris ile de france et enfin
dominique baiser bonsoir mon chemin vous
êtes délégué général du syndicat
national de l'alimentation et de la
restauration rapide
merci d'avoir accepté tous les cas votre
invitation à leur première chose
marquante ce sont les nombreux projets
réalisés ou à venir sur saint quentin en
yvelines et aux filles
aux environs alors une première question
ont vu de la multiplication de ces
projets sur 51 est venu dans un
périmètre assez serré pourquoi tant
d'implantation j'ai envie de vous
demander pour commencer est ce qu'il
faut faire la restauration rapide pour
gagner de l'argent
la personne alors la question de la
question qui est posée
difficilement on va essayer de trouver
une réponse pour trappe qui sera
forcément différente ce qui avait pas de
grandes chaînes de restauration sur
trappe tels que vous avez annoncé et
jamal l'oréal qui a ouvert au mois de
décembre
voilà donc on à l'arrivée d'un
mcdonald's on sait qu'on a un burger
king qui en qui a déposé son permis
donc on l'a peu près 1 6 mois à peu près
déchéance d'une création d'un dab burger
king aussi attrape la question ne se
posait pas parce qu'on n'avait pas de
grandes chaînes de restauration et donc
le signal qui est envoyée si vous voulez
par rapport au fait qu'on ait des
nouvelles implantations de ce type
c'est un signal positif pour la ville de
trappes ça signifie que c'est une ville
qui se normalise
jusque là on n'avait pas de grandes
chaînes de restauration parce que
peut-être qu'il y avait aussi une peur
une crainte de s'installer peur qui
était légitime ou pas je reviens pas là
dessus mais en tout cas maintenant on
est sur un la création notamment de
nouveaux quartiers et donc l'arrivée de
nouvelles chaînes de ce type est plutôt
un signal positif aussi bien en termes
d'emploi on y reviendra aussi bien en
termes de de rayonnement de la vie
sociale c'est à dire quand vous avez
aussi une chaîne de ce type là et que
vous en fait bénéficier aussi de
nouvelles clientèles l'ensemble du
commerce local
et puis et puis de d'urbanisation de la
ville parce que ça fait partie la paul
mcdonald et puis pour le futur burger
king de nouveau créé de nouvelles
créations d'entrée de ville notamment et
pour le mac donald's d'une nouvelle
urbanisation de la rd 912 qui se refait
de façon parallèle 912 c'est là c'est la
mine droite on va appeler ça qui mène à
la base de loisirs entre à la base de
loisirs est elle en cours
nota c'est ça dominique venise et le
fast food c'est un c'est un truc qui
marche en ce moment tout cas tout le
monde envie de faire de façon on a parlé
de mcdonald's on a parlé de burke qui
sont de deux mastodontes on va dire du
secteur mais il n'ya pas que oui alors
déjà je ferrais ne pas parler de fast
food de restauration rapide voire même
de restauration à service rapide avec ce
qu'on ne monte pas aux clients de manger
rapidement dans le restaurant
ce que le client attend dans le
restaurant c'est d'être servis
rapidement donc il serait plus judicieux
de parler de restauration à service
rapide
je crois que lorsqu'un établissement de
notoriété comme ceux que vous avez cités
s'implante quelque part d'une part c'est
après avoir fait une étude de marché et
d'autre part dans son objectif c'est de
s'insérer dans le tissu économique local
ça veut dire que pour lui ça répond à
une attente des consommateurs potentiels
de venir consommer dans cet
établissement évidemment et on s'est
aperçu dans un certain nombre de villes
de province notamment qui était plutôt
en sommeil au niveau activité économique
que l'implantation en centre ville
même dans des villes anciennes dans
scènes comme celle ci était générateur
de fréquentes de nouvelle fréquentation
des commerces alentour
que ce soit le marchand de journaux
que ce soit les commerces
un jury devrait apporter savent
redynamise le périmètre si vous voulez
qui se situe autour du restaurant qui
s'est implanté donc c'est le côté
positif très nettement de ses
implantations également sur le niveau de
l'emploi
lorsqu'il s'agit de grandes chaînes
comme celle ton inciter tout à l'heure
ce sont des créations d'emplois aux
alentours alors ça dépend de la taille
de l'établissement de son implantation
et c'est épuisant facteurs qui entrent
en ligne de compte mais on peut compter
sur une moyenne de 50 emplois créés par
l'ouverture d'établissements les
chiffres exacts je vous ai vu faire la
mule c'est le bon bah c'est ça mon camp
quand on parle d'emploi effectivement on
pourrait se dire a priori que l'arrivée
de ces enseignes
une bonne nouvelle car ils créent de
l'emploi mais c'est vrai ce qui est vrai
mais pas de grand soir on n'a pas
forcément une image complète de la
réalité des choses il faut là il s'agit
là d'une vision à court terme il faut
aller cependant plus loin et s'est
intéressé à la condition de ces
travailleurs lorsqu'ils sont embauchés
par par ces entreprises le contrat que
l'on signale embauches
d'abord c'est un contrat à temps partiel
qu'on nous impose un accord on ne le
demande pas ce contrat temps partiel
donc là on nous l'imposent directement
le dirai pourquoi ce qu'on impose un
temps partiel ah bah non on demande à
voir des temples indirectement puisque
sont des contrats à temps partiel de
l'isère rémunérés sur la base du taux
horaire du smic
donc concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire on est embauché à 24 heures
par semaine sauf pour les étudiants qui
peuvent avoir moins 24 heures par
semaine pour 790 euros net par mois donc
avec un tel salaire bien entendu on est
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
impossibilité de se loger donc
obligation de travail abreuvant de
chercher un deuxième emploi et là encore
c'est pas évident puisque
del embauches on nous demande des
disponibilités très large
par exemple si vous travaillez à 25
heures par semaine on va vous demander
maximum d'avoir 75 heures de
disponibilité dans la semaine donc on
travaille à temps partiel mais on nous
demande d'être disponible sur du temps
complet donc on nous dit que c'est plus
compliqué d'aller chercher un autre
travail pour complément pour
complémenter pour compléter par dont le
travail
bien souvent c'est même impossible les
coupures sont autorisés dans la
restauration rapide les coupures se veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que en tant que
salarié je vais devoir travailler dans
mon restaurant le midi je vais avoir une
pause de 3 4 heures l'après midi et je
vais retourner au restaurant le soir
donc qui voudra de vous l'après midi
pour vous donner un emploi alors c'est
tout le monde va répondre juste après
krieger dynario alors vous vous êtes
restaurateur restauration traditionnelle
est ce que ce sont aussi des des types
d'emplois que vous proposez pour la
restauration de type traditionnel
précisément dans la restauration
traditionnelle tout est différent
alors que nous proposons pas du tout la
même chose que la restauration rapide
puisque la restauration rapide répond à
un besoin de se nourrir alors que dans
la restauration traditionnelle nous vend
donc plutôt vers nous vendons nous
proposons un moment de sortie de
convivialité un moment de plaisir
donc c'est très différent au niveau de
l'offre commerciale ce que nous
proposons c'est un moment de détente et
c'est aussi très différent en terme
d'emploi et d'avenir pour les salariés
qui travaillent chez nous il n'ya pas de
temps partiel chez nous très peu ce sont
des vrais métiers d'avenir ne peut bâtir
toute une carrière produire une vie une
famille et c'est donc l'effet de la
multiplication des chaînes et autres de
restauration rapide à saint quentin en
yvelines sur la restauration
traditionnelle n'est pas très évidente
on est content on serait temps d'enfin
aurait tendance à penser qu'on n'est pas
très touchées sauf pression on prend une
démonstration simple on prend par
exemple une rue ou même restaurant digne
traditionnelle et une restaurant à pile
à côté ça va donner un certain
on prend la même rue on met le même
temps restaurants traditionnels
on met cinq restaurants rapides à côté
même s'il faut pas la même chose y aura
forcément un autre résultat donc il ya
un phénomène de dilution de la clientèle
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'on voit
pas tout de suite mais ça existe donc
l'arrivée de beaucoup de restaurants
rapides sur saint quentin en yvelines a
priori bon ça répond à une demande
vous c'est la quantité est évoquée vous
avez forcément la prolifération par
megal la puissance financière du
restaurant de vin d'une chaîne de
restauration rapide
c'est palin sur la même que celle d'un
indépendant faisons un métier
d'indépendants par essence par
définition ce qui fait aussi notre
charme de notre côté on va revenir sur
tout à l'heure sur la puissance
financière de dd en scène que vous avez
cités peut-être une réponse sur ce type
d'emploi thomas hardy ou de dominique
bénézet ce que j le bon bar pour un thé
à l'instant des emplois certes mais des
emplois plutôt précaire alors est-ce que
vous souscrivez à ça ou pas non je ne
peux pas accepter sur le terme de
précaire puisque 90% des emplois qui
sont pourvus en restauration rapide sont
des contrats à durée indéterminée
c'est donc le contraire de la précarité
en revanche il est vrai que on a entre
75 et 80%
deux contrats à temps partiel alors
pourquoi pourquoi parce que le
consommateur
le législateur ni revient plus jusqu'à
présent consomme entre midi et deux
heures et entre 19 et 21h donc c'est ce
qu'on appelle dans notre jargon le roche
ces quatre heures par jour donc deux
heures le midi deux heures le soir on
réalise 80% du chiffre d'affaires est
entre les deux vous pouvez aller dans
tous ses établissements de restauration
rapide avant midi le matin même si vous
voulez y prendre un petit déjeuner ou
entre 14h et 18h 19h vous n'avez
quasiment personne c'est pourtant la
même chose qui se passe dans les
restaurants traditionnels
la clientèle vient manger aux alentours
de midi jusqu'à 14 heures il ya une
coupure quand ses deux occupants
par expérience de travailler dans un
restaurant non pas jusqu'à 15 heures et
puis à 18 heures et à la reprise pour le
service du soir mais ça fait quand même
une journée qui la coupure n'est pas
prise en compte ne ça fait une journée
de 8h à peu près mais les coupures sont
prises en compte maintenant
simplement on s'efforce de réduire ces
coupures parce qu'on a bien conscience
que pour un salarié alors surtout en
région ile-de-france demandé un salarié
même si on essaye de recruter des
salariés qui sont à proximité des
restaurants demander au salarié qui a
mis une heure pour venir de repartir
chez lui et de revenir après qu'est ce
qui lui reste chez lui valurent et c'est
une heure donc notre convention
collective tient compte de seuil et de
ces cas là de même que vous évoquiez la
disponibilité dont doit faire preuve un
salarié à temps partiel
je rappelle aussi que la convention
collective de la restauration rapide
prévoit le travail le cas d'employeurs
multiples et sans les employeurs de la
restauration rapide s'engage à favoriser
le lan ploie multiples parce qu'on a
bien conscience que si un salarié à deux
employeurs que l'on nous donne ses
congés au mois de juillet et l'autre au
mois d'août
ça revient à dire que le salarié n'a pas
de congés donc ça c'est inacceptable
alors j'entends bien mais puisque vous
parlez de d'emploi aux multiples si il
n'y a pas assez de temps pour aller
justement cherché un autre employeur
comment comment répondre ce que disais à
l'instant j'ai vraiment si c'est du cas
par cas par cas le salarié qui souhaite
avoir un deuxième employeur qui a une
touche passez moi l'expression un peu
triviale pour avoir ce deuxième en gros
c'est possible c'est normalement
possible d'abord thomas hardy pu abréger
le combat mais moi j'aimerais juste
revenir peut-être la genèse du projet
mcdonald's parce que c'est un mcdonald's
sera pu être autre chose pendant trois
ans la zac de la queue on en train de
créer une zac zone en gros de
concertation
urbanisme nouveau dans trappe on a un
nouveau quartier qui est clos et on
s'est dit automatiquement il faut penser
la question de l'emploi c'est en gros la
question du tertiaire au sein des
nouveaux quartiers très souvent vous
avez des tertiaires qui sont séparés des
zones de logement et donc vous avez des
zones qui sont inhabitées le soir parce
qu'il ya plus de d'employés donc là
l'idée c'était vraiment de créer au sein
de cette zac
une zone qui soit tertiaire on est resté
pendant trois ans quatre ans peut-être
cinq ans sans réponse de la part
d'investisseurs donc ou en tout cas la
casse qui nous a pas fourni de la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin de proposition sérieuse et du
coup on s'est retrouvé sans aucune
proposition en fait sur cet acte là on
s'est dit on va s qu'on abandonne à ce
qu'on la borne aime pas et là on a eu
cette arrivée de mcdonald's l'intérêt de
mcdonald's alors ça aurait pu être autre
chose c'était qui viennent souvent en
binôme dire vous avez manuel plus une
autre chaîne
là en l'occurrence de restauration
plutôt traditionnelle et ça va être pas
tout à fait le cas mais c'est aussi
agrémenté quand vous avez le burger king
qui va venir à l'emplacement du
crozatier futuropolis
vous aurez avec un picard et puis une
boulangerie ange donc l'intérêt c'est
aussi qu'ils viennent pas simplement
tout seul mais avec d'autres emplois
d'autres employeurs et d'autres emplois
pour le mcdonald's automatiquement on a
pris contact avec le créateur en lui
demandant automatiquement de réserve et
de le plus possible d'entendre alors
autres à piste ho trappistes il se
trouve que c'est aussi la politique de
mcdonald's et c'est tant mieux
mais après vérification donc maintenant
on est allé à l'ouverture du mac
donald's trappe on a plus qu on a pu
voir en direct pour un avantage 55 cdi
sur les 60 proposait donc 60 cdi
effectivement peut-être nous on va pas
défendre tel type d'emploi plutôt qu'un
autre on se dit que c'est déjà un
tremplin alors c'est une vision qui peut
pas être ni moyen de termini long
termiste
excuse moi de l'expression mais
effectivement il faut consolider la base
des emplois il faut que un jeune puisse
être autonome avec son emploi mais en
l'occurrence pour ce qui est de trappes
c'est vrai que beaucoup de ces jeunes
que j'ai rencontrés m'ont dit
qu'effectivement c'était au moins une
opportunité d'avoir une première
expérience
alors c'est pas un argument en tant que
tel c'est pas un argument tant que tel
de se dire bon on va s'en tenir à une
première expérience etc
mais vous avez quand même 55 personnes
sur ces 60 qui ont ils se disent
maintenant qu'ils en sont contents parce
que j'ai jaugé un petit peu
de l'enthousiasmé de ces jeunes là
qu'ils sont contents qu'ils habitent à
moins de deux kilomètres du lieu de
travail et qui pour le coup vont avoir
une première expérience
beaucoup m'ont dit quelque chose de que
j'ai gardé en tête depuis le début de ce
mandat c'est que quand on va postuler à
l'extraire de trappes oublié de mettre
50 et en yvelines on peut pas mettre 60
10 890 trappe parce que c'est mal vu
et donc ils ont du mal aussi avoir un
premier pied dans l'entreprise quels
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs vos c'est un
tremplin
c'est un tremplin et c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle c'est le bon bar alors
plutôt une bonne nouvelle même si on n'a
pas forcément répondu sur le temps
partiel temps partiel est une c'est pas
si grave que ça pour dominique ce soir
c'est le teint partielle de temps
partiel quand on choisit a pas de
problème quand on nous l'imposent c'est
un problème
enfin jean j'entends bien aux arguments
enfin là les salari que vous avez
rencontrées au mcdonald's de trappes
je mets au défi d'y retourner dans un an
vous allez voir ça sera une toute autre
équipe et le turnover le taux de
turnover qui est extrêmement élevé à
l'autre le taux de turnover c'est le
taux de rotation des effectifs sur un an
dans un établissement ses taux en
général sont extrêmement élevés il frôle
parfois les 100 % dans certains
restaurants plus ce taux est élevé plus
cela est révélateur d'un certain mal
être au travail
alors pourquoi j'emploie ce terme de mal
on n'en a pas encore parlé mais les
conditions de travail sont bien souvent
difficiles cela est dû au sous-effectif
que l'on subit pour servir les clients
les contraintes de temps aussi qu'on
nous impose on doit servir des clients
dans sept ans dans un certain délai et
bien souvent ce sont des jeunes des
étudiants aussi qu'on va rentrer dans
ses restaurants là et a abandonné bon
alors je suis moi même étudiant mes
consignes pour que ça se pratique pour
les étudiants ça leur permet de dadié
bon tanger tétouan refait les gestes qui
auraient pas besoin de toi même offerte
et donc j'ai trouvé moi aussi un intérêt
ça permet de financer mes études à un
permis d'avoir un petit peu d'argent de
poche
mais sur le long terme ça devient
compliqué de travailler en subissant des
conditions de travail pas très pas très
bonne c'est difficile de concilier
études et travail d'où les taux de
turnover extrêmement élevé dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
alors justement avant de vous donner
messieurs la parole pour répondre à ce
que vient de dire j'ai bon bah on va
écouter l'avis des saint-quentinoise et
des saint quentinois
nous sommes allé leur demander ce qu'ils
pensaient du développement des
fast-foods désolé ce crime au cola comme
des fast food par l'agglomération pour
les écoutes ou soucaret beaucoup mais
peut-être que par rapport à la
population étudiante
ça correspond je sais pas alors je pense
que c'est un marché intéressant mais
faut pas qu'ils soient trop gros quoi je
trouve qu'il y en a beaucoup
ça monte de plus en plus ça près du
moment que les jeunes travaillent bien
et que ce soit propre nourriture soit
saine ya de la place pour tout le monde
bonne chose concurrence importants
puissent aller se résigner montain le
choix de manger ce qu'ils veulent pour
tous les étudiants aussi c'est bien déjà
parce que ça fait un petit peu de boulot
on peut travailler à côté puis je pas
trop cher aussi pour moi après ce qu'ils
ont autant de qualités c'est bien c'est
une question parce qu'en terme de
qualité c'est bien c'est une autre
question c'est la question qu'on
pourrait vous poser créé cardinal en un
petit une petite réaction sur ce que
viennent de dire les saint quentinois
les saint quentinois j'ai entendu à
plusieurs reprises l'houmeau il y en a
beaucoup
j'ai entendu parler aussi à l'instant
parler
des auditeurs de qualité est ce que
c'est bon pas bon est ce que c'est bon
pour la santé
donc ça ce sont des questions qu'on
pourrait se poser il s'agit quand même
de la nourriture de fans de nourriture
industrielle avec ce qu'on peut supposer
comme agréments aux désagréments pour la
santé mais à côté de ça par rapport à la
multiplicité des chaînes de restaurants
rapides
on pourrait aussi se poser la question
savoir pourquoi il n'y a pas de
simplement de bistrot de petites
brasseries à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est à dire un tissu commercial dans ce
domaine un peu plus classique un peu
plus famille l'âge du rumen ce sont des
bonnes questions à se poser
effectivement monsieur beaucoup de
commerçants par exemple à l'espace saint
quentin se plainent peut-être d'une
homogénéisation à venir de l'offre
alimentaire c'est-à-dire avoir plusieurs
façons qui vont s'installer
et puis du coup tous les troquer les
petits bistrots petit à petit vont
commencer à fermer d'ailleurs on en
prend un exemple
c'est un type comme spot qui va
remplacer imprimeurs qui était l espace
saint quentin
alors comment vous voyez ça cette
crainte peut-être et des commerçants
d'une part et peut-être de certains
clients avoir de moins en moins de
diversité dans l'offre alimentaire
dominique belize et je pense pas qu'on
puisse parler de moins de diversité
j'aurais tendance plutôt à parler de
davantage de diversité sur votre
reportage envoyé en arrière-plan un
restaurant asiatique
on voit de plus en plus d'un restaurant
de ce type que ce soit en restauration
traditionnelle à 6 ou en restauration
rapide s'installer à côté de sean que
vous qualifiez tout à l'heure de fast
food je remets le terme entre guillemets
donc on a plutôt une diversité de
l'offre
à laquelle on assiste ce qui est plutôt
une bonne chose sachant que le
consommateur est de plus en plus a peur
c'est à dire qu' une vingtaine ou une
trentaine d'années le consommateur
allaient tous les midis dans la même
brasserie pour prendre son déjeuner ça
c'est terminé depuis longtemps et le
consommateur est nappée de temps en
temps et de se faire livrer un plateau
repas parce qu'il est en réunion sur son
lieu de travail
de temps en temps il a fait revivre une
pizza de temps en temps il va aller au
mcdo
et puis de temps en temps il va aller
chez monsieur s'il est un peu plus de
temps et qu'il a peut-être un client a
invité parce qu'il va être dans un cadre
différent et où ça va être une
restauration différentes
il y as je crois une complémentarité
entre les différentes formes de
restauration et en france aujourd'hui
seulement un repas sur sept et prix hors
domicile et dans ce repas sur cette
prieur domicile y en a la moitié qui
sont pris en restauration collective
donc on est très très loin des taux de
prise hors domicile
d'autres pays européens et puis les pays
anglo saxons notamment
alors thomas ailleurs dit puisque
effectivement attrape par exemple le
mcdonald's qui a ouvert au mois de mai
alors excusez-moi des sites à chaque
fois mais bon c'est la réalité et se
sont installés remettre dolan est à
peine 200 300 mètres à vol d'oiseau
il ya un autre burger king qui va à qui
va s'installer alors excusez moi
peut-être d'être naïf mais pour moi m de
la laverie rck et c'est un petit peu la
même chose c'est du hamburger en général
donc quelle est la logique est ce qu a
une cohérence dans dans ses
installations pourquoi pas une fois que
mcdonald's installé au quai sont là
pourquoi pas mais tu sais pas une autre
chaîne alimentaire d'alimentation un
autre restaurant autre chose ou
carrément autre chose il ya deux choses
d'une part c'est qu'on choisit pas
l'arrivée d'un investisseur 1 que ce
soit mcdonald's burger king ou autre à
chaque fois ce sont des propositions qui
nous sont faites qu'on a validée parce
que ça nous a semblé intéressant
burger king effectivement est dans une
phase où il revient en france il y en
avait une cinquantaine au moment où il
est venu nous parler ce projet là on en
a parlé un petit peu rapidement autour
de nous et on a vu un effet positif dans
la population nous à dire ah super
bernard king bon voilà nous je vous
avais dit le signal du mcdonald's était
plutôt positif c'est à dire que ça à
faire rayonner aussi l'économie au
niveau local et puis ça permet peut-être
des gens qui sont jamais venus à trappes
de voir que c'est une ville comme les
autres voilà ça c'est la première chose
on ne choisit pas la deuxième chose
c'est que
venir des restaurants traditionnels
c'est une vraie politique pour le coup
une vraie politique volontaire
volontariste dire que autant on a eu ces
propositions qui sont venus
de la part d'investisseurs que tels que
mcdonald's burger king autant faire
venir un restaurant c'est pas du tout
évident il faut que que les élus mettent
une vraie volonté dans la politique pour
implanter des restaurants donc nous
attrapons n'a souhaité une
diversification des restaurations
on est en cours et donc c'est on ne
reparlera peut-être dans quelques années
mais alors à l'heure actuelle au centre
ville par exemple on vient de créer deux
brasseries qui viennent de s'installer
sur la rue jean jaurès donc c'est un
signal déjà important de brasserie de
bouche voilà deux du midi c'était
important de trouver ce lieu d'accueil
un lieu de passage avec convivialité
c'est aussi ça qui fait un peu la vis au
niveau 2 au niveau local et ensuite au
niveau du des merisiers ça fait
plusieurs années
peut-être trois ans qu'on a laissé la
possibilité à n'importe quel
restaurateurs de venir s'installer au
sein de ce quartier qui s'est refait de
a à z de venir s'installer et donc on a
pas eu de réponse pendant un certain
temps et là on a eu enfin des post it
est ce que vous voyez en fait ce qui se
passe et qu'on urbany cette ville de
manière maintenant moderne c'est donc
devenu esthétique et donc ça commence à
intéresser les gens et donc il a fallu
beaucoup de temps avant que quelqu'un
vienne s'installer mais à quel prix
c'est dire que la commune décide
d'acheter une part un appartement du bas
un combat d'idées qu'on va détachées
pour être un commerce futur à l'avenir
et donc on va créer un bail qui sera qui
sera pas très élevé de façon aussi à
intéresser et donc c'est de cette
manière là qu'on fait une politique
volontariste pour faire venir des donc
des restaurants sur la ville lorsqu à
long terme les restaurants traditionnels
vote dans la difficulté
ce qu'apparemment il ya un déséquilibre
qui peut se faire on a parlé tout à
l'heure un emploi à temps partiel par
définition payer des employés à temps
partiel
ça coûte beaucoup moins cher que des
employés à temps plein alors est ce
qu'on peut parler de concurrence un
petit peu déloyale entre les restaurants
les types rapide et les restaurants de
type traditionnel ce qu'on appelle les
deux restaurations concurrence déloyale
ni puisqu'on joue pas tout à fait dans
la même cour devant pas les mots c'est
pas la même chose on ne vend pas la même
chose comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
maintenant il ya quelque chose que je
vous ai relevé c'est que vous avez
monsieur que nous sommes comme les
autres à trappes on a un mac do bon
c'est quand même un peu étonnant comme
expression cirque au travail et une
mauvaise banque
vous trouvez ça dommage c'est un peu
étonnant une ville trappe j'aime
beaucoup trajet des amis autres
hop je fréquente le marché des merisiers
attrape j'y vais régulièrement un des
plus gros d'île de france
oui donc je connais bien trappe j'ai
vécu une grande partie de mon enfance
avec des amis à trappes j'ai joué au
foot un trailer met donc une ville et
qui dit on est comme les autres on a un
mcdo c'est quand même un peu surprenant
ses marques rapidement
juste une précision c'est pas la formule
que j'ai employé j'ai dit c'est un bon
signal et ça veut dire que c'est une
ville effectivement qui se normalise
dire que vous avez n'importe quelle
ville de 30000 habitants dans le bassin
à dd grande richesse de restauration
fait quelle qu'elle soit jusque là on
n'avait aucune ça voulait dire ce que ça
voulait dire c'est que sans le côté un
peu la ville alors s'installer en
attrape était jusque là quelque chose
d'impossible on avait l'impression en
tout cas il y avait aucune aucune grande
enseigne qui venait sur la ville là la
chose le signal qui est positif c'est de
se dire qu'on devient une ville comme
les autres mais attention ça veut pas
dire que notre projet ce soit d'avoir
plusieurs fast-food que ce soit
uniquement salle projet c'est à dire que
pour être normal il faut un mcdonald's
dans la ville c'est pas ça c'est pas mis
en gt300 jaurès on va laisser un mois
j'ai le bon bah on arrive bientôt à la
fin de l'émission ce sera votre
conclusion j'ai dit oui non mais bon au
niveau des services que propose
maintenant la restauration rapide
enfin on est quand même sur une volonté
de vaud de vouloir
rattrapé quelques services que propose
la restauration traditionnelle le
service à table par exemple est pratiqué
par beaucoup de restaurants donc il ya
cette volonté de mcdonald's et d'autres
enseignes de vouloir voilà avoir
beaucoup beaucoup d'offres pour offrir
enfin pour avoir une clientèle très
large au final après enfin j'aurais
quand même un mot à dire ce sera la
conclusion rapidement en tant qu'élu
enfin certes vous faciliter
l'instauration de ces restaurants sur le
territoire mais il faut aussi après voir
ce qui se passe donc je parlais tout à
l'heure de la condition sociale de ces
travailleurs de 6 que vous intéressé de
savoir si ces enseignes la paye ou pas
après l'impôt sur les sociétés on
s'était un sujet majeur
mcdonald's est sous les feux de la rampe
en ce moment puisque pour des causes les
raisons fiscales notamment une plainte
qui a été déposée par un comité
d'entreprise dont je fais partie isolée
de vous couper alors il faut dire on
ferme conclue rapidement de fraude
fiscale
vraiment 10 secondes maintenant rien à
rajouter
non on regarde pas forcément la couleur
de l'argent
on a parlé d'une enseigne on ne refait
pas d'une autre ce qui était intéressant
c'est surtout que on commence à être
attractifs et que des gens commencent à
s'installer à travailler c'est ça la
bonne nouvelle
rapidement après 13 heures 10 secondes
très rapidement joueurs réagir sur ce
que dit monsieur bompard
la restauration rapide est le premier
secteur de la restauration commerciale à
avoir une convention collective en 1988
depuis on a signé avec les partenaires
sociaux dont vous faites partie plus de
60 accords et avenant et fair l'évasion
fiscale rapidement je rame prononcé par
quelques des procédures qui sont en
cours et sur le turn over laissez-moi
terminer je vous ai pas interrompu sa
seconde saison je vais me faire tirer
les oreilles sur le turn over
il y à une partie de ce turn-over qui
est lié au fait que les salariés
acquièrent en restauration rapide
une connaissance du service et ils sont
débauchés par des enseignes -
contraignantes au niveau des horaires
notamment pendant les repas puisque en
restauration de travail pendant les
repas que sont les enseignes de
bricolage ou d'ameublement par exemple
c'est obligé de vous couper merci
blessures en tout cas c'est un débat
très intéressant
vous pouvez nous retrouver sur le site
de tv fuit le tfc tv fil 78 points comme
pardon ou sur le twitter hashtag 7,8
société on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau débat merci